what is this this is uh what in the
world
uh this is a thing it's good sculpture i
don't know
no 20. wow it's killing it
hey guys it's max and vadim and today we
are doing another blind camera
comparison between the brand new s21
ultra
the note 20 ultra and the s20
ultra to find out is it worth spending
the extra money or is it worth upgrading
or should you buy an s20 for as low as
700 links are in the description
go ahead and grab a piece of paper and a
pen and
join us vote to see which one ultimately
wins so here is the first image i took
all these images
some i know which was which i copied and
pasted the
the shuffling kind of effect so i don't
know which one is which on this one
they're very similar they are very
similar i've been looking at this for a
while because it's the first one
i'm gonna go with the one in the center
the one on the left looks a little bit
kind of
flat i guess and the one on the right
there are
areas that are blown out like on the
screen so i think i like the center the
best all right
i'm gonna vote for the one on the left
and i am voting as well
even though some of these i'll know
which one are which this one i don't
and you got no no twenty and i got the
s20s
right off the gates sorry s21
and now we have a telephoto shot right
here i mean instantly center
center one this one is noticeable now so
much better here's what i'll say yeah
i took two shots with this one just for
the facial expression look at this
these other ones actually took about
five to seven shots
and i chose the best one center one is
s21 ultra so it got a point right away
that is good
and for those of you guys wondering
where is angelica well she's not feeling
well right now so she couldn't join us
leave her a nice comment down below that
would be awesome
next shot is my beautiful brunch i think
i like the one
in the center i feel like it's the most
sharp
i don't know i mean they're just so
close they are close i'm gonna go with
the
center okay i'm gonna go for the right
because
this is also sharp these are all blurred
out here
yeah kind of like it i don't know let's
see s20
you got the s20 i got another s21 and
the weird thing is
all of these have 108 megapixel main
sensors next shot we got a portrait here
out of all of these i can tell that
there's more detail in the sign on the
one in the left and i do like the
kind of blur roll-off it's very natural
as well yeah
it looks very realistic i'm voting for
the left as well
no 20. good job no 20. that's a first
for me did you get no 20 yet yeah
you got one i got two of those all right
we got another portrait shot here this
is a wide portrait
obviously the one on the left i mean
just look at the detail in his hair
just instant these are all like i don't
know
and he was moving around too so it
grabbed him shutter speed
yeah all right this is an ultra wide
shot here okay
i think i'm gonna go with the rights i
feel like i'm seeing more detail
in general and i feel like the
highlights are
the least blown out so hdr is the best
so nice so
right once again i have no idea what
what is what here i'm going to go with
the left just because i like it's more
moody
how it's all darker here as far as the
atmosphere
s20 and you got to know 20. it's killing
it
and we have some delicious coffee and
espresso here
so the one on the right i feel like the
espresso is more blown out there and it
looks kind of cool in like blue you know
so the colors look kind of weird what
coffee do you want to drink
i feel like the one on the left looks a
little bit too blurry like um
depth of field i think i'm going with
center me too
now we have a selfie shot in some mixed
lighting conditions and
oh man i don't know if i like any of
them i mean honestly i'm gonna go with
the one on the left
i feel like the detail looks good
but the other two are a little bit kind
of like over
contrasted i mean look at your eyes
they're just so black there and here you
can actually see like high detail
yeah you're right this i look like a
demon or something
all right on the left s that's 21.
that's good
another mixed lighting situation
daylight and then you have like the
really warm light from the fire
center instantly like absolutely look
how detailed it looks great everything
looks
sharp her hair wow and white balance
wise it's the best two i think it's
really good
blurry too blue
hey they're doing something right hey
this is a lot yeah it's standing out
compared to the last comparison yeah all
right we got this flag shot
some beautiful mountains in the
background yep so it's gonna be
the one on the left it's hard both of
these look good even though we have a
white balance difference this looks like
garbage
they look good i kind of like how the
sky is more white
here more looks kind of more natural i
vote for left two
no 20. no way no this is a 10x zoom shot
no way i i don't know it's crazy and
then we have hey
yeah so wide portrait shot
look at the bokeh there that looks so
realistic
i'm still going with the leftover
because you can see so much more detail
in his face
and a lot of his jackets much more
detailed
i agree that's 20 ultra wow
why is it so much sharper comebacks i
don't know it doesn't make sense
maybe it doesn't have to think as much
to do boca
i don't know we have uh coeur d'alene
resort here
one on the right's definitely bad yeah
horrible but between these two
i think i'm gonna go with the center i
like the warmer color detail it looks
like this is a little bit more
detailed to me if you look at the
railings
i'm going to go with the left which ones
you choose center center
okay you got no 20 20. i know that's a
big shift right there
the these are 108 megapixel images so
it's not zoomed
it's yeah and then i i digitally uh
zoomed into them
and this is an ultra right here honestly
i think i know what
i choose can i guess what you're going
to choose i don't know if you want to
first decide what you're going to choose
then i'll guess
i'm going with the center center yeah
that's what i thought you would go with
yeah
i'm going with the right because i like
contrast all right
that's 21. i got the s20 and this is a
zoom shot
right instantly wow it's so much more
detailed
especially if you look at the texture of
the the stone brick there yeah
okay 21 21
and so this is actually this is the
three times zoom
so it has an optical three time zoom
yep and these are digital crops so good
job samsung
and this is a macro shot
interesting why are they so different
this is just the best the cameras could
do with macro macro okay
all right so this is a macro shot but
i'm still going with the right
i like that the detail looks really good
and you know
everything just looks better okay so i'm
choosing the center anyways
i know which one the center is um this
so this is as close as you can possibly
get
these images look more interesting so
you could have done that with this
camera
this one just allows you to get insanely
close i was like this far away
that's cool no 20 and s21 so the s21 is
crazy
as soon as you get close to macro it
auto flips the lens it doesn't even tell
like it doesn't tell you it's switching
to a different lens
and allows you to get insane like a this
would be like a b
or something like massive on here
alright so we have
a portrait shot very difficult one i
will say you have all these cables that
need to be cut out
i'm definitely going with the left i
really like that one the detail looks
really good detail on his face and hair
and that one is the s21 and i agree
it looks it looks better and the blur is
definitely better because they all did
good
and here we have an ultra wide shot
it's between the center and the right
and i think
that the one on the right does a better
job because it's
not as blown out you can kind of see
some text in those signs
with that it also looks sharper i think
if you look closely
i think so yeah it does look a little
sharper too yeah everything
asked and we have a portrait shot
at night with some nice trees in the
background i'm gonna go with the right
because
the one on the left looks pretty good
but just so much noise in the jacket
that's true yeah the center just lacking
detail
i'm going with the right okay i don't
know which one is which
i'm going for the center because i love
how the that vocal looks right there
that reminds me of an actual dslr it's
pretty good um
these aren't bad but i'm going to the
center
all right mixed lighting indoor shot
with
uh this cool motorcycle i'm gonna go
with the
center i feel like it has the best mix
of
detail and dynamic range with like not
blowing out that light
and everything just looks i think
balanced i'm gonna go with the one on
the left
because i like a little bit extra
contrast no 20 that's 20.
wow the 21 to the worst yeah it's the
white balance is kind of off here
right look at her face and everything's
kind of just a little bit too bright or
brought up a little bit more
and we have what is this this is uh what
in the world
uh what do you call it uh this is a
thing it's a sculpture
i don't know yes this is a sculpture
there's a lot of differences here if we
look at them okay i didn't even look yet
i think the one on the left has the most
detail
and i like the white balance in general
i kind of like that one the best yeah
and the dynamic range
too it looks good yeah this is look how
dark everything in the background super
dark and then yeah and this is way too
warm i like a lot of detail
yeah no 20. wow it's killing it
and we have the medicus building here
this is night mode so we're getting into
the dark stuff now
center center kills it with the detail
man yeah hey i'm surprised you're
choosing a photo that has more contrast
i mean just look at the detail and like
that sign isn't as blown out you could
actually kind of like
read it compared together so all right
um i vote that too
no no but i voted for the contrast i
hate it when
nighttime photos yeah when they don't
look like night time
these ones still do but i like the
nighttime photos to have good dynamic
range and good content
take a look at that okay i know which
one looks the worst
this one looks horrible to me yeah it
looks pretty big it looks like it's
i don't know what it definitely doesn't
look like nighttime
i mean i think i'm gonna go with the one
on
the left i don't like how much contrast
it has like his
jacket is so blast there but in terms of
the detail
and like that whole riverfront thing
it's very sharp there too so i guess
i'll add in
it was dang dark like their faces were
super dark
way dark it was darker than even this
yeah so that this is
all right s20 what how's the oldest
phone have the best photo
i guess these are pretty close that's
crazy all right and
we have another one now this was like
super bright underneath this kind of
bridge overhang
super dark in the background so it's
interesting how different these are
uh i mean i feel like i'm going with the
center even though like it was actually
dark outside yeah if you it's just like
this type of a photo i don't know it
looks more sharp everywhere too this is
the one you'd want in your phone i think
yeah if you're trying to see something
at night yeah s20
again jeez okay so this is flipping once
we're getting to night mode shots
alright so this is a nighttime portrait
shot
i mean i feel like the one in the center
i mean it's more
sharp um you can see those dots on her
dress definitely more sharp they
pop out more compared to the the one on
the right just looks really bad this is
definitely the worst the the detail the
white balance is
all off the one on the left looks a
little bit too flat
all right that's 21. this was
very dark out what in the world man okay
yeah i mean the one on the right i mean
you could look see all that detail
within that building
and like the colors really pop and the
sky isn't as
like i guess artifacting yeah there's
just so much
artifacts noise whatever that is yeah
this part looks terrible though if you
compare this to
this but i just cropped that out yeah
you would just craft this photo
um i yeah i have to agree this is just
so flat because you're trying to see
they had it right
yeah yeah i think so
all right and we have another nighttime
portrait
super dark dark right yeah the one in
the center killed it with everything
there's less noise there's more detail
and actually looks pretty good and this
yeah i took like seven or eight shots
with this phone couldn't focus
it couldn't focus focus yeah s221
and here we have a nighttime selfie
portrait obviously the one obviously
this one
smokes it wow this looks like trash
better than the previous iphone 11. we
can say that i guess so
yeah you can see my face actually but
yes the left that's
21. it's good all right and we have
another portrait shot
of these blocks which is very difficult
at night
all right this is tough but i think i'm
gonna go with
before you say right which you're not
going to say right look at that what is
that
yeah i guess it does look like you clean
it oh it's going to go with the right
because it has more detail but hey i'm
not supposed to
give you advice you mentioned it now i
notice it
it's the center i mean it's kind of like
the best mix of
being clean having detail yeah yeah
center
me too that's 21 that's 21. okay i'm not
going to say anything out until you vote
all right we have i think we're almost
at the end here we have the famous
red wagon this is an ultra wide
nighttime shot and it was
i couldn't even see this it was like all
black so all of these are awesome but
i don't like the one on the left i feel
like it's too flat
for this time i think i like the one in
the center because you still get color
like in the
bark grass all this stuff you get more
color yeah whereas this is kind of like
heals the color like
doesn't even look like a red wagon so
i'm going with the center yeah
um i see what you say about the left one
yeah but i like having the color in the
trees here and i feel like has a little
more detail
so i'm going with the left so left okay
s21 you got another one and i believe
this is our last shot
this is shooting across the street and
there's a lot of differences here
yep one on the right i think does the
best it looks the most detailed by far
look at the wheels and um look at the
background
i like it yeah i like it kills it like
look at the tree look at
the leaves too that's a lot of detail
you're making me change my mind video
what you're you're going a different one
i was gonna go with the one in the
center it is a little blurry
yeah but this looks kind of over
sharpened i'll i'll stick with my center
one all right stick with that one
no it's is that the last one
that is the very last one so all right
you guys go ahead and pause this video
count up what you have we want to hear
which one you voted most for or what you
voted
and if you were surprised by any of the
results so vadim you hold on let me
count up mine okay
all right guys we have our results
hopefully you wrote yours down below
if you didn't please do i'll go first
now mine wasn't unbiased
yeah i would say probably about seven
or eight of these i knew what they were
a lot of them i actually didn't know
um so my results were i had five points
for the note 20 ultra eight points for
the s20 ultra and 17 for the s21 ultra
so it's surprising
that the note 20 actually got worst
place for me
for you yeah um and the s21
smoked it but of course mine was not
unbiased so it's not that i was unbiased
vadim's was unbiased other than one time
i convinced you to change your mind
i have seven for the s20 ultra
i have 11 for the note 20 ultra and 12
for the s21 ultra that is close only one
more
for the latest newest phone all right
guys well we're excited to hear your
guys's results yep
and it looks like unless you're max and
you're biased and you know which one of
some of them are which
either these phones did extremely close
and they are they're both great at what
they do and you can buy one of these for
about
200 bucks less up to 300 less probably
yeah big difference in price
and has some advantages we actually did
a detailed comparison and the
s20 still did really well i actually it
beat out the note 20 in my case it's not
bad
700 bucks on amazon you can buy it for
right now really instead of 1400
700 bucks a good deal i guess we'll
we'll link these down
in the description check out our other
videos right over there we have a couple
of awesome comparisons this has been max
and team
and we will see you guys in the next
[Music]
video